bonjour aujourd'hui on est alex thomas
qui a un robot après son rebond c'est ça
c'est un robot compagnon de vie pour
chien un coin repos compagnons du
porcien
c'est un truc de dingue
est ce que tu peux nous présenter les
serres l'ancien donc enchantés de thomas
sens man et cofondé can't take est une
serre tête du cou qui développe laïque à
un laïc a donc c'est un compagnon de vie
pour chien c'est un robot qui va
permettre d'interagir à distance avec
son chien
donc tout simplement en fait on prend le
contrôle du robot avec son téléphone sur
lequel on a un retour vidéo en direct
donc on va pouvoir se balader chez soi
et voir son chien mais on va aussi
pouvoir lui parler on pourra vous
prévenir quand lui aboie de manière
répétée pour pour éviter de nuire à vos
voisins ou juste parce qu'il se passe
quelque chose chez vous qui peut lui
parler tu as dit c'est ça dont il ya des
sons qui se comprennent enregistrés dans
l'implication pour éviter de jeter tous
les collègues dans l'open space
sinon vraiment en mode talkie walkie
pour lui parler en direct
voilà on a aussi intégré inventaire de
friandises donné c'est à dire que donc
voilà ici là il ya le lanceur et donc on
à la trappe avec le réservoir ici permet
de commander une trentaine à peu près
dix décès vraiment pas de nourrir le
chien mais c'est vraiment plus de la
récompense est apparu que calibre et du
coup tu comme à mettre alors on
on fait tout ce qu' on n'a pas voulu
justement limit et no no no client à
devoir acheter nos friandises donc en
fait tout ce qui rentre dedans le
diamètre qui fait 1,6 cm dont le dans le
lanceur
ça fonctionne donc même si elles sont un
peu ovale un peu un peu carré tout ça a
priori ça passe on un peu disert chien
si jamais il tombait trop alors sa part
pas trop c'est quand même propulsé
rentes ai pas fait un petit un petit
mètre mais on va la sauver le chien non
plus c'est pas l'idée l'idée en fait
c'est vraiment justement de pouvoir
stimuler le chien en fait avec le robot
mais l'idée c'est aussi de pouvoir
l'éduquer avec parce que ben on a design
et le robot de manière à laisser aucune
aspérité dessus pour pas que les chiens
puissent le prendre en bouche
maintenant c'est aussi important de
présenter le robot chien et de l'éduquer
avec pour qu'il en est ni peur et qui
soigne et agressif avec ben parce que
voilà ça face à un berger allemand
bassa'a c'est un berger allemand donc
voilà maintenant une fois justement
qu'on fait toutes ces étapes de
présentation et nous dans l'application
donnera un certain nombre de deux
conseils on fera des vidéos avec des
professionnels du secteur des
vétérinaires des comportementaliste
justement pour expliquer tout ça et que
ça allait mieux mais une fois que nous
on est on est pas loin des 200 tests en
soi
donc donc on est très content de tous
les tests qu'on a fait on est content de
la résistance du rombo les chiens à 6000
quand même assez vite
comment ça marche le fait que ses
relances des friandises cesse à se
déplacer que tout quand il roule contre
s'il se retrouve là le rythme tombe aux
mains soit en soit il peut se
effectivement c'est un accès c'est
quelque chose qu'on a qu'on a choisi en
fait de deux pas de ne pas faire le fait
qu'il puisse se remettre à l'endroit
nathan serait rajoutée en fait beaucoup
au coût de production du robot a
maintenant le truc c'est qu'en fait
c'est beaucoup plus dur qui passe comme
ça hein comme ça que l' inverse vraiment
pas sa forme en fait et par l' équilibre
du robot et puis en fait les chiens
comprennent aussi assez vite qu'une fois
qu'il est comme ça le robot marche plus
on est d'accord et donc en fait assez
facilement ils vont venir va taper
dessus et très vite il va revenir un
endroit donc c'est vraiment plus par
action du chien en fait voilà on s'est
dit là pour le coup le robot alors on
est en campagne de financement
participatif sur indigo donc là le robot
avec sa base de rechargement et son
tracker est aux alentours de 130 euros
ok donc 400 euros à terme une fois qu'on
sera en magasin chez animalis par
exemple donc on voulait pas voilà
ajouter encore au cou c'est ça c'est
déjà un budget on est en les conditions
et on fait au mieux pour pour limiter
donc ça ça faisait partie des dunes des
choses qu'on a décidé de limiter donc tu
suis le chien tu peu long et des
friandises tu peux communiquer avec lui
ouais qu'est-ce que tu as comme
interactions encore alors il ya un autre
mode aussi lyon qui en fait le mode
autonome à dire que même quand le
propriétaire est pas disponible pour
interagir avec son chien à distance mais
en fait le robot est capable de se
déplacer chez vous de manière
complètement autonome avec la défection
la détection d'obstacles donc il sort de
sa base de rechargement et aux ballades
et on fait aussi un petit tracteur qui
va sur le collier du chien
l'accord permet en fait de mesurer
l'activité du chien donc on va savoir
justement quand le
allez vous coucher dans un coin qui se
repose et qui vaut mieux le laisser
tranquille
et quand est-ce qu'ils courent partout
dans la maison et donc à ce moment-là on
envoie une petite notification et si le
propriétaire n'est pas dispo babala est
capable de se balader chez soi et
divertir le chien détourner son
attention l'idée c'est vraiment de
pouvoir améliorer en fait de son
bien-être
pendant que les gens partent travailler
on est pas du tout là pour substituer le
mettre dans le sens où on répond pas aux
besoins primaires du chien et ça va
venir ça va pas les frais en dise c'est
pas pour remplacer sa gamelle
on sort pas le chien le sociabilise pas
avec ces autres congénères
voilà là nous ce qu'on fait c'est
vraiment créer un lien en fait entre
vous et votre chien quand lui est tout
seul
ils sont un peu moins seul c'est ça ok
ok voilà il ya il ya un site internet
sur lequel on à la mairie sur alors du
coup back and day point fr je suis tout
mettre dans la description pour
rejoindre et puis et puis pour le coup
que dire d'autre ben on va aussi
représenter la france
aujourd'hui on est on est à journées
internationales de business france donc
on va représenter la france à
l'international on compare aux crs de
las vegas avec business france justement
d'ailleurs on a gagné un petit award
dans la catégorie robotique aliotti est
là pour le coup c'est vrai qu'on en ait
vraiment content donc
donc voilà n'hésitez pas à faire un
petit tour sur note site internet sur la
page facebook forcément camtoya fr et et
plus n'hésitez pas cool merci beaucoup
avec plaisir bon je vous invite à aller
voir tout ça vous met tous les liens
dans la description vous mettez un petit
commentaire vous me dites ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous avez un chien oui non
on peut pas du tout petit avec un chat
c'était pour et sasha
alors on traîne par rapport aux par
rapport à ça on voulait pas en fait
faire un produit qui soit entre les deux
la grande chez le chat sont deux animaux
bien différent et des comportements
différents tout ça et on voulait pas
justement ne répondre ni vraiment alain
denis vraiment à l'autre on s'est dit on
va commencer par les chiens on fera une
solution connectée pour les chats mais
dans un deuxième temps d'accord sur mon
cou en 2018 si les choses vont bien je
te le souhaite
merci donc est donc allé voir tout ça
vous marque et ça en commentaire et puis
vous allez les suivent de près parce que
je pense que ça va être une solution qui
va être hyper intéressant qui ça se
développe énormément sur les animaux de
compagnie merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
vous invite à vous abonner qui aura de
plus en plus de contenu sur la tête et
puis moi je vous dis à très bientôt
salut